that's what most people here when they
cycle but this is how it sounds to event
Ian's cry seek a dull Rumble in traffic
her impairment could mean the difference
between life or death with a hearing aid
it's easier for me to hear cars that
drive up behind me it's safer but
nevertheless stereotypes persist that
hearing aids are just for funsies that's
an outdated image in the past hearing
aids used to be a lot bigger nowadays
they're much smaller you can hardly see
those most people don't even know I have
one these two businessmen sell hearing
aids made by different companies the
devices are often only as big as a bead
and cost up to 2800 euros with life
expectancy growing and an aging
demographic in many European countries
hearing aids a big business one in three
people over 50 has hearing problems but
only 20% of them actually wear hearing
aids that's a lot of potential and
enough work for decades to come
OD beanies started up in 2012 and
already employs 350 people in Berlin
alone some asked first of all you need
to get your doctor to check your hearing
they are advising potential customers
discussing the various options and
whether they might be eligible for a
free device it's not an easy job many
people find it difficult to admit their
hearing isn't up to scratch staff get
Commission on their sales and even
occasionally a gong and the team award
for this week goes to Lin's team
worldwide Rd Benny employs 800 staff in
nine countries profits are being plowed
back into the expanding company most
people featured on their website are
youthful looking the kind of people who
wouldn't want anything to do with dated
devices but would like sleek
inconspicuous aids ones that can even be
completely concealed in the ear
basically this is about the holy grail
of eternal youth the generation we
encounter are baby boomers who are still
very active and often still working and
now they're confronted with the annoying
fact that they can't hear so what in
some loud environments this customer
also bought his hearing aid online now
he's getting the device adjusted by an
expert
[Music]
[Laughter]
Torsten mark Fayed always wears his
hearing aid no matter where he is it's
almost invisible he can also use it like
very expensive headphones he regulates
the music using an app on his smartphone
he doesn't see it as an accessory for
oldies I don't get the feeling that
people around me perceive it as a device
for old people if you get your
smartphone out and show people you can
listen to music with it then everyone
immediately thinks that it's pretty cool
when you want to listen to what's going
on around him again he has to reset the
device
thanks to this new technology having
impaired hearing is no longer a problem
for 29 year old Torsten Marquardt